how do you get over feeling like an
impostor as a new manager I feel like
I'm about to get found out
welcome to leadership here's the thing
here's what you're actually scared of
what you're scared of
most likely is them knowing and finding
out that you don't know everything right
right that's what people don't like to
admit when they're wrong yeah yes and
the thing that you need to know is it's
okay it's okay not to know everything
it's perfectly normal to be in a
leadership position and not know
everything in the world you don't have
to know everything about this particular
job that you're going into or what you
don't need to know everything you don't
need to what you need to do is go in ask
questions listen to people and say ain't
no what I have done this procedure
before I've never I never worked with
this piece of equipment before can you
show can you walk me through it you show
me how to do it mm-hmm I just want to
make sure I understand what you're doing
make sure I get it oh okay now it's not
an excuse to not know anything because
if you're in a leadership position you
should be studying and reading and
learning about whatever the role you're
in that you can understand it all study
the manuals and the regulations and the
procedures and I'm not saying to follow
all those things blindly without common
sense no that's not what I'm saying but
there's a knowledge base that you should
you should acquire very quickly when you
roll into a leadership position so put
the work in and then apply common sense
but this is the same thing that I say
every time somebody asked me about how
do you lead this or how do you lead that
or how do you lead new people or how do
you leave senior people it's the same
answer every time be humble
hmm listen to them beyond time work hard
treat people with respect weigh the
decisions carefully talk to people and
then make a good decision
empower your folks to lead don't
micromanage them but give them at the
same time clear guidance about what the
expectations are it's just leadership
and when you're a new leader it's all
good you don't need to know everything
you're not expected to know everything
and showing that you could admit that
you don't know everything isn't gonna
hurt your reputation it's actually gonna
help your reputation so go in be humble
ask some good questions learn as fast as
you can and it's okay and you know I was
thinking about this um in the 80s and
perhaps even in the 90s when guys were
losing their hair and going bald right
they do a comb-over mm-hmm so they try
and pull their hair over their balding
scalp so it didn't look like they were
going bald right and I'm telling you as
a leader don't do a leadership comb-over
yeah and what guys do now which is they
just shave their head right okay good
you know what I'm going to get up top
all good just gonna shave it off hey I'm
your new leader don't know everything
it's all good
you know here's where here's where I'm
weak give me a hand yeah no big deal
that's a good analogy don't do the
leadership comb-over what tell me if you
would agree with this
it generally speaking um emotionally
demolition man with the best alone
Wesley Snipes
negative anyway Dennis these names Denis
Leary it doesn't seem like your kind of
movie but maybe it was would be I don't
know anyway Denis Leary he's this kind
of underground rebel because basically
la is a long explanation okay I'm ready
so I'm all about leadership basically
the you know it's in the future whatever
and the world is turning into this like
over sensitized like you can't swear he
can't eat junk food it's the law like
you know so everyone's all nice and real
weak and stuff like that but there's a
guru who rebelled against it went
underground right and the leader of
those guys is called egg Edgar friendly
right and so they go down and he's
regarded as this huge criminal right the
demolition comes back long story about
him but anyway he's back to help rid the
world of these criminals so he goes any
encounters Edgar friendly and they're
not Ravel they're not these evil people
they're just like just trying to live
basically a
freedom a free life you know and they're
like oh he's like hey well why don't you
lead these people out of here right and
he's like I'm the leader sometimes I
gotta do some shit and people come with
me right that's kind of what he says so
isn't this his so here's the question
sorry for long explanation
how this guy's he's kind of like worried
about people finding him out that he's
not a leader right isn't that like a
huge sign of humility that he's like on
the inside he's not yeah I know what
everything you don't like that I don't
know at all you know and I'm worried
about this it's actually a good sign you
are correct yes a good sign when you got
someone's neck man I want to do he wants
to do a good job he wants do a good job
and he said worried about it so that's
that is good that is a good thing yeah
it's like his humility is like is so
genuine that that's one of his many
worries of being a leader you know it's
a good sign it's better than someone
says you know what I'm about to take
over as a new leader yeah I'm on this
end I'm good I know everything and no
one knows anything that I know so it's
gonna right yeah you don't be that guy